Ah, yes. Offside,...
...taker-away of scoring chances and confuser of casual soccer fans everywhere.
Is it frustrating at times?
Yes, of course.
But it's also an important, invaluable rule.
Without offside, there'd be no need for perfectly-timed through balls and crosses,...
...nor perfectly-timed runs combined with gravity-defying headers.
The game would be mayhem, chaos, a catastrophe.
So, what is offside?
If the assistant referee raises his flag,...
...it means that an offensive player was too far forward.
According to FIFA, a player is in an offside position...
...if he is nearer to his opponent's goal line than both the ball and the second-last opponent.
The key is realizing that offside is determined by when the ball is last touched.
When Daley Blind hit his amazing ball over the Spanish defense,...
...Robin van Persie was clearly onside, with two opponents between him and the goal.
Only after the ball left Blind's foot did van Persie streak past the defense.